it is the 2nd of february 2022 so it's
time for another monthly update video in
which i'll tell you about what we've got
coming up in february
and about what what what went on in
january what you might have missed what
you might want to go back to
i always like to begin by highlighting
three big things
so big thing number one is a little bit
of a longer term matter
andy and i have been asked once again to
organize the big international stoicon
conference which will be happening
online again in october so you'll see a
lot of stuff going on about that in in
months to come
big thing number two also stoicism
related the stoicism reddit
is uh having me do a
ama session with them coming up in this
month so that'll be interesting and then
big thing number three this is really
kind of a big thing
we haven't done any in-person
face-to-face events
since the beginning of covid
we are going to be doing our first this
month uh starting back up the philosoph
the the philosophers in the midst of
history
series with a session on plutarch so
i'll talk about that in the
february section of this
so what went on in january well it was a
long and very busy month
i struggled with some
illness towards the end of the month
that
wound up with me not getting as much
done as i'd like i've been very tired
had some headaches and
actually had to cancel class
one day
that wasn't in january though that was
yesterday so february 1st
i did do a lot of online events we had
the ama that's asked me anything
my hegel q a in discussions
uh we did a political theory
uh
uh discussion about foucault and power
that was that was quite fun
um scott and i did our classic metal
class
and then i also led a seneca reading
group that meant met every
monday for
about two hours and of course my
academic classes started at milwaukee
institute of art and design and i was
getting ready for the carthage class
that starts today
so that was that's kept me pretty busy
i've also been doing a bit more writing
in medium and of course being on the the
radio shows that i co-host wisdom for
life and drive time from river west
uh did some interviews as well
um we had
massimo pigliucci on the drive time show
we had
donald robertson on wisdom for life
and i've also had a lot of tutorial
clients a lot of new clients and a lot
of old clients some consulting some
philosophical counseling so that has
been
you know making my days pretty pretty
packed i did get to the gym
uh quite a few times although as i got
sick and very very tired
that
has hasn't been the case for the last
week or so right
videos i shot a number of videos i got
three half hour hegel videos in the
religion section done one book review
video i did another one of those wombo
taking you know a prompt using my
master's thesis
uh hussarl's
passive synthesis and the constitution
of language as a prompt so i did i did
that as well
there's videos from all the events which
you can easily find by clicking the show
more or video description i'll put links
to all of those
below
i did some sadler's stories videos and i
also released a number of the
earthsea
videos those were from tales from
earthsea
and
i finished up with core concept videos
on foucault on the subject in power and
that's what led me into deciding to
focus on that for the political theory
and application discussion
i i also did a contest
having to do with a podcast
saying what should we do
should we
do aristotle should we do deluge should
we do anselm should we do aj air and you
know i'm actually going to do all of
them it was just a question of what
order and i was very surprised to see
that aristotle's politics book one
took precedence and
people really got into that
so
that's what i started doing
last month after i finished up with all
the other podcast stuff that i was
releasing and working on so busy busy
month um you know again
uh cut short in part because of just
being worn out
but you know still got quite a few
things done
all right what do we got coming up in
february so
beginning on the 5th at 12 and these are
all central times so you want to make
sure to check your time zone we'll have
the
monthly ask me anything general ama
session that's the place to go by the
way if you want to
get involved in live events and you want
to ask me questions about things that
aren't particularly relevant to any one
single event you want to go to the ama
on the fifth at two philosophy chat for
my patreon supporters a little perk that
i provide them with
on the ninth we will be having
that aforementioned philosophy in the
midst of history session going to be
focusing on plutarch a lot of people
don't think of plutarch as a philosopher
but he really is i mean half of his
writings are biographies and there are
pretty philosophical biographies and
then half are what are called the
moralia his essays on all sorts of other
matters so i will be doing that at the
frank weinberg library on the uh
the 9th at 6 pm it'll be an in-person
event
big haul
everybody has to be masked up we will be
recording it you see my tripod back
there and so if you if you don't make it
to it you can at least do that i'll be
using my voice recorder to you know get
some decent sound even though i'll be
masked up we'll see how it goes
on the 10th we will have the first of
the
readings for the month from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation we're now
getting into part three
of the book that'll happen at noon
and those will be happening on the 10th
the 17th and the 24th
so each of those is is something you
might go to
on the 19th at noon we scott taruli and
i will be having our classic metal class
that is carried out through zoom and the
topic this month is going to be
parody metal bands and whether what
they're doing is really metal or or not
and so we've got a lot of you know
talking about everybody from spinal tap
to steel panther and all sorts of things
in between should be a very interesting
session
on the 23rd at 1 pm that's a wednesday
we will be
beginning the stoicism reddit ama which
goes for 24 hours so i'll be there for
the intensive early part of it and then
i'll be checking in every so often and
answering other questions hopefully it
remains you know fairly
even and you know we're able to uh
answer all the questions who knows what
it'll turn out like though
on the 24th 6 p.m uh mke stoic
fellowship we're actually
this time going through diogenes leote's
discussion of stoic doctrine that's what
people wanted to work through and
discuss so that should be quite
interesting
then on the 26th saturday beginning at
noon we will be doing the next worlds of
speculative fiction
series and we are going into philip
pullman's his dark materials
series um
uh you know the golden compass the
subtle knife and the amber
spy glass
so i'll be talking about these and you
know world building
cosmos building since there's multiple
worlds and philosophical themes that are
coming up and that is the stuff for the
month i mean there's also
the radio shows you know wisdom for life
airs on saturdays
at 5 00 p.m central and drive time for
river west i'm on there every other
wednesday
from 4 to 6 p.m
contributing as a co-host to that so
that's what's coming up this month as
far as events goes
um
classes are in full swing now uh with
you know my third class beginning today
got a lot of people lined up for
tutorial consulting and philosophical
counseling to the point where i'm
probably going to have to start saying
pretty soon
that i can't take on new clients until
down the line i'm sort of at capacity i
think at this point in time
a lot of video production
scheduled we'll see if i get to all of
it
i'm releasing the final earth earthsea
videos that is the books that i shot
the videos that i shot on the last book
of earth c for my class that i taught
last semester
hopefully can you know shoot a lot of
half hour hegel videos
got a lot of book review videos i need
to do
there's a few
personal videos that i might shoot
having to do with like my philosophical
development or other matters
sadler stories videos people seem to
like those we might do a caption contest
or something like that
and then i'm in the process of producing
core concept videos for my medieval
philosophy class
beginning with prudentius's psychomachia
i won't have to do too many on that but
it's it's kind of a cool text
and then uh
augustine's
confessions
uh we're going through the entirety of
that
in my class so that will be um you know
quite a few core concept videos on that
once the earth see videos have come out
and you know we'll see what else i can
get around to producing obviously
there's a lot of um other videos that
are going to be released you know over
the course of the month from you know
wisdom for life or the uh
worlds of speculative fiction as a video
premiere all the streaming events will
will be showing up as well
uh the podcast i
as i mentioned you know we did aristotle
i've been releasing some videos on
deleuze's
short
essay
about bartleby the scrivener there's not
too many of those but then we have a ton
of podcast episodes on anselm's
monologian
and if we get through all of those then
i will do the ones that i've been
meaning to do on aj air's language truth
and logic so
those are
all the things that are going on at
least in part you know i'm sure there
will be some other things that pop up
from time to time
i hope to see some of you in
these online events and if you're in the
area and you can make it to the frank
weinberg library for this in-person
event you know i invite you to show up
and learn a little bit about plutarch
and middle platonism and all the other
cool stuff that was going on at the time
in history
otherwise i will see you in the ether
and i hope you have a great month ahead
you